last summer there was The Curious Case
of Scott Rowan who uh told reporters in
Southern California that he was set on
fire on the sidewalk because he's gay
the the truth eventually did come out uh
precisely 3 days later I want you to
watch as the same crack news team that
brought you the original story pulls
what maybe the single biggest about face
in the history of Journalism was earlier
this week Scott Rowan who was gay told
us he was set on fire in a targeted
attack in San Diego investigators paint
a different picture they say they got a
911 call that night of a Man attacking a
pregnant woman she was bleeding and had
several injuries requiring her to go to
the hospital an hour later officers got
a report of a man saying he'd been set
on fire officers determined the man with
the burn injuries was the suspect in the
attack on the pregnant woman now we
learned that the gay guy was actually
beating a pregnant woman to the point
that she was bleeding and had to go to
the hospital and while she was being
attacked she somehow set the gay guy on
fire in self-defense